en este vídeo vamos a hablar un poco
acerca del orden de las operaciones y
debes prestar mucha atención porque todo
lo que hagas en matemáticas dependerá de
qué tan sólido sea tu conocimiento en
este tema
pero qué significa cuando digo orden de
las operaciones déjame explicarte el
punto más importante es que existe una
única forma de interpretar una expresión
matemática
por ejemplo tenemos la expresión
7 3 x 5
si no existiera un acuerdo en el orden
de las operaciones habrían dos formas de
interpretar esta expresión
la primera leyendo de izquierda a
derecha podrías decir primero eres 73
y luego voy a multiplicar eso por 5
entonces si primero haces 73
eso te da 10
luego multiplicas te 10 por 5
10 x 5 te da 50 por lo que el resultado
es 50
esa es una forma en la que puedes
interpretar la expresión
tal vez sea automático leer de izquierda
a derecha otra forma de hacerlo es decir
me gustaría hacer primero la
multiplicación y luego la suma entonces
quedaría si primero hacemos la
multiplicación 3 por 5
y luego eso
3 x 5 es igual a 15
y luego hacemos la suma entonces 715 es
igual a 22
nota que interpretamos la expresión en
dos formas diferentes aquí en esta
leyendo de izquierda a derecha primero
haciendo la suma y luego la
multiplicación en esta forma haciendo
primero la multiplicación y luego la
suma pero obtuvimos dos respuestas
diferentes y eso está completamente mal
en matemáticas de hecho si esto fuera
parte de un esfuerzo para enviar un
satélite hacia la luna ya que nos
persona lo interpretan de formas
distintas y una ingresa en una
computadora de esta forma y la otra
persona lo ingresa de esta forma el
satélite en vez de llegar a la luna
llegaría a marte es por eso que es
completamente inaceptable y se debe
tener un acuerdo en el orden de las
operaciones
un acuerdo en cómo interpretar las
expresiones
así que el acuerdo de cómo interpretar
las expresiones es hacer primero lo del
paréntesis
escribí bugs
[Música]
luego hacer los exponentes vamos a
escribirlo
[Música]
si no sabes que son los exponentes no te
preocupes luego la ofrecerá en este
vídeo no habrá expresiones con
exponentes así que no debes preocuparte
por eso aquí
después de los exponentes
sigue lo que sería la multiplicación
y
en el mismo nivel la división cuando
vivo en el mismo nivel quiere decir que
estas dos operaciones tienen la misma
prioridad
y finalmente está la suma y la resta
que como los anteriores están al mismo
nivel de prioridad
así que este es el orden de las
operaciones marquemos lo con una llave
esto es el orden de las
operaciones
siguiendo este orden de operaciones
todos debemos conseguir el mismo
resultado al aplicarlo a una expresión
veamos cuál entonces es la forma
correcta de interpretar nuestra
expresión de acá arriba
dice primero hacer los paréntesis en
nuestra expresión no hay paréntesis los
paréntesis lucen de esta forma como dos
curvas alrededor de los números
también haremos algunos ejemplos que
tengan paréntesis más adelante
dice después los exponentes en este caso
no tenemos exponentes pero si tenemos
multiplicación así que el orden de las
operaciones dice as primero la
multiplicación en este caso aquí está la
multiplicación así que esta operación se
debe hacer primero
y luego la suma
por lo que si hacemos primero la
multiplicación tenemos 3 por 5 igual a
15 y luego sumamos con 7 eso quiere
decir que la respuesta correcta
es 22
en el acuerdo de las operaciones la
respuesta correcta es esta de aquí esta
es la forma correcta de interpretar la
expresión
hagamos otro ejemplo y creo que esto
dejará las cosas más claras
digamos que tenemos la expresión 73
entre paréntesis por 4
entre 2
15 por 6
así que muchos operadores aquí pero si
solo nos apegamos al orden de las
operaciones el problema será más simple
y claro lo primero que debemos hacer de
acuerdo al orden de las operaciones es
lo que está dentro del paréntesis
en nuestra expresión tenemos paréntesis
en este lado encerrando 73 por lo tanto
lo primero que debemos hacer es sumar 73
esto nos da un resultado de 10
y luego queda que multipliquemos eso por
todo lo que está en la derecha con lo
cual lo voy a cortar y a pegar
para no estarlo discrimina
después
lo que sigue es hacer de acuerdo al
orden las operaciones los exponentes en
esta expresión no hay exponentes sin
embargo si tienes curiosidad acerca de
cómo luce un exponente aquí está un
ejemplo por ejemplo 7 al cuadrado donde
el 2 como cuadrado se representa como un
número pequeño en la esquina superior
derecha como no tenemos ningún exponente
aquí entonces no nos preocupamos por eso
después hay que hacer la multiplicación
y la división en esta expresión tenemos
varias multiplicaciones bueno tenemos
dos multiplicaciones y una división
cuando tienes operaciones en el mismo
nivel de prioridad
como aquí lo que se hace es seguir el
orden de izquierda a derecha por lo cual
nosotros vamos a realizar primero
esta de aquí que sería 10 por 4 10 por 4
es igual a 40
y normalmente vamos a copiar y pegar lo
que nos sobra este lado
después de haber realizado la primera
multiplicación siguiendo el orden de
interpretación de izquierda a derecha
vamos a continuar con la división 40
entre dos también tenemos después que
hacer la multiplicación de cinco por
seis lo que nos dice el orden de las
operaciones es que la suma y la resta
están al final de la prioridad por lo
cual esta resta se va a hacer después y
nos vamos a ayudar de otros paréntesis
para poder distinguir que estas
operaciones van antes que la resta
aunque puedan ser indistintamente que se
haga la división o la multiplicación
vamos a seguir el orden de
interpretación que es de izquierda a
derecha por lo cual 40 entre 2 es igual
a 20
- 5 x 6 que es 30
finalmente hacemos la resta que es la
prioridad final del orden de las
operaciones de 2030 lo que nos da 10
negativas
entonces esta es la forma correcta de
interpretar esta expresión matemática
así que quiero dejar bien en claro una
cosa cuando uno tiene operadores en el
mismo nivel por ejemplo como aquí
12 - 3
4 - 1
la suma y la resta están en el mismo
nivel de prioridad uno debe interpretar
este tipo de expresiones de izquierda a
derecha por lo que tendríamos 12 es
igual a 3 menos 3 más 4 - 1
después siguiendo el orden 3 - 3 es
igual a 0
4 - 1
siguiendo el orden tenemos 0 44 menos 1
y por último 4 menos uno es igual a 3
entonces debemos interpretarlo de
izquierda a derecha al igual si nosotros
tenemos una expresión con divisiones y
multiplicaciones como
4 x 2
entre 3
por dos vamos a ir de izquierda a
derecha por lo que 4 por 2 es igual a 8
entre 3 por 2 luego 8 entre 3 no es
igual a 8 tercios lo vamos a dejar aquí
en fracción por 2
y por último ocho tercios entre dos es
igual a 16 x vamos a hacer de izquierda
a derecha no podemos decir primero voy a
hacer la división y luego esta
multiplicación y así no hay que respetar
el orden de izquierda a derecha la única
situación en la que pudiéramos pasar por
alto el orden de izquierda a derecha con
los operadores al mismo nivel de
prioridad no es cuando tenemos
expresiones donde solo por ejemplo hay
sumas como en uno más 5 + 7 3
+ 2
tenemos puras sumas entonces si podemos
tomar 73 es igual a 10 más 5 igual a 15
más un 16 más 2 igual a 18
eso pasa igual cuando sólo tenemos
multiplicación
bueno tenemos un 1 por 5 por 7 por 3 por
es la única forma en la que no importa
que sea lo que operemos primero solo
cuando tenemos operadores iguales